islamic state was one of the most
powerful terrorist organizations the
world has ever seen
at the height of its power it controlled
a territory the size of britain
a population of 8 million and an army of
around 100 000 fighters
now largely driven out of its territory
in the middle east
its ideology lives on and is taking root
in africa
the sahel is an arid belt of land that
stretches across north central africa
it is predominantly muslim poor and
badly governed
the perfect conditions for extremist
groups to thrive
many of these terrorist groups pledge
their loyalties to is or al-qaeda
the deadliest terrorist factions in the
world are in northeastern nigeria
boko haram promotes a version of islam
which forbids muslims to take part in
any activity associated with western
society
in 2017 it used at least 135
child suicide bombers iswat a splinter
group of boko haram is now the biggest
is-affiliated group in the world
its mission is to create the next
caliphate nigeria is the most populous
country in africa
with the biggest economy if terrorist
groups take hold here
they could destabilize it and much of
west africa
causing a greater refugee crisis
the number of violent incidents
involving jihadist groups in africa
has increased by 300 since 2010.
many african islamic terrorist
organizations benefited from the death
of libya's former dictator
moammar gadhafi smuggling networks would
develop to get weapons out of libya
and into the hands of jihadists
on the eastern side of africa based in
somalia
is a terrorist group al-shabab it
pledges allegiance not to is
but al-qaeda it controls many rural
areas
where it imposes a strict version of
sharia law and is believed to have as
many as 9
000 fighters western powers are trying
to contain these terrorist groups
the g5 sahel a counter-terrorism
alliance with troops from
mauritania mali burkina faso
niger and chad america also has troops
in africa
but the trump administration wants to
cut their numbers
this will mean more responsibility will
lie on european shoulders
something they are unlikely to accept
you